[Music]
um
[Music]
every year we herald the coming of
christmas by turning on the lights
and light does more than create a
festive mood
light brings hope for christians
jesus is the light of the world but we
can't celebrate his birth today
in quite the usual way people of all
faiths
have been unable to gather as they would
wish for their festivals
such as passover easter eid
and visakhi but we need life to go on
last month fireworks lit up the sky
around windsor
as hindus sikhs and jains celebrated
diwali
the festival of lights providing joyous
moments of hope and unity
despite social distancing
remarkably a year that has necessarily
kept people apart
has in many ways brought us closer
across the commonwealth my family and i
have been inspired
by stories of people volunteering in
their communities
helping those in need in the united
kingdom
and around the world people have risen
magnificently to the challenges of the
year
and i'm so proud and moved by this quiet
indomitable spirit
to our young people in particular i say
thank you for the part you have played
this year we celebrated international
nurses day on the 200th anniversary
of the birth of florence nightingale
as with other nursing pioneers like mary
seco
florence nightingale shone a lamp of
hope across the world
today our frontline services still shine
that lamp for us
supported by the amazing achievements of
modern science
and we owe them a debt of gratitude
we continue to be inspired by the
kindness of strangers
and draw comfort that even on the
darkest nights
there is hope in the new dawn
jesus touched on this with the parable
of the good samaritan
the man who is robbed and left at the
roadside
is saved by someone who did not share
his religion
or culture this wonderful story of
kindness
is still as relevant today good
samaritans have emerged across society
showing care and respect for all
regardless of gender race and background
reminding us that each one of us is
special
and equal in the eyes of god
the teachings of christ have served as
my inner light
as has the sense of purpose we can find
in coming together
to worship
in november we commemorated another hero
though nobody knows his name
the tomb of the unknown warrior isn't a
large memorial
but everyone entering westminster abbey
has to walk around his resting place
honoring this unnamed competent of the
first world war
a symbol of selfless duty and ultimate
sacrifice
the unknown warrior was not exceptional
that's the point he represents millions
like him
who throughout our history have put the
lives of others
above their own and will be doing so
today
for me this is a source of enduring hope
in difficult and unpredictable times
of course for many this time of year
will be tinged with sadness
some mourning the loss of those dear to
them
and others missing friends and family
members
distance for safety when all they really
want for christmas is a simple
hug or a squeeze of the hand
if you are among them you are not alone
and let me assure you of my thoughts and
prayers
the bible tells how a star appeared in
the sky
its light guiding the shepherds and wise
men
to the scene of jesus's birth
let the light of christmas the spirit of
selflessness
love and above all hope guide us
in the times ahead it is
in that spirit that i wish you a very
happy christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
amen
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the glories
[Music]
is
you